How long do you think you're going to live?
60, 70, 80 years?
Okay, we'll give you a hundred,
but don't be fooled because many people die
way younger than that.
But let's say, your cut off date
or death date is 100 years, then what?
Have you prepared or thought about
what's to come next?
Now, what's my purpose
or goal in telling you this?
Well, it's to inspire you, to think deeper
into the reality of this short,
fleeting transitory life.
How many of us have seen friends
or family members, that you loved
or some that you even hated,
but now they're gone. You've lost them.
Doesn't this rattle something inside of you
to think deeper into where they go?
We were just arguing, joking, laughing together,
but now they're no more.
We somehow think that we are going
to live forever in this life,
as if science is going to develop a pill
that will extend our lives forever.
For those of us, who have been living
for some time,
if you just look at  the process of age,
something very obvious,
when you just look at some of the old pictures
of when you were young,
but now we're becoming older,
we were once full of strength,
but now we are going in reverse
and becoming older and weak.
You get into a routine, for many of us
it stays the same – wake up, work, work out,
hang out, sleep.
Some eagerly awake the weekends,
just to be able to make it to the bars
or the nightclubs.
Where men lust over women
like an animal on the hunt for his prey
and sadly women go to these places
putting themselves on display
and becoming some horny dog's prey.
Waking up the next day with a nasty hangover,
feeling guilty and doing the walk of shame.
And then, just to do the same thing
the next weekend, but this time
you might have an STD.
Is this what life is about?
Fulfilling one's desires at the expense
of losing one's soul?
Now, your intuition tells you
this can't just be it – Baby Mama Drama,
sports, party, play entertainment,
alcohol, drugs, chasing all the material things.
There has to be more to this life,
than all of these superficial things.
An ultimate goal, a true purpose
to your existence to why am I here on this earth
and where am I going when i die.
You see, my goal was to motivate you to reflect,
ponder and think to the reality of this life.
The reality of death and the common sense
question that all of us should be asking.
What is the purpose of my life?
Why am I here?
Now, it's up to you to do something about it.
Thank you for listening.
Subscribe if you haven't already
to the Deen Show.
Peace be with you.